hey youtubers is charlie so hbl released
a trailer for a bunch of its stuff
including some new footage from Game of
Thrones season 6 so I'm just gonna use
it as a good opportunity to talk about
the Bolton's so I'm gonna play the
trailer see if you can spot the new
stuff then we're gonna break it down are
you here this place this powering you do
you feel I've been afraid to use it but
I can't be afraid anymore I have been
reborn and I can see the future how
about that huh did you see that coming
this year has been magical that was love
fine danger dragon dragon strike
it was 50 shades of grey what is very
singular meet me put it right up high
you want to get out of here
we're going on a mission
all the way back to the beginning of
time
this is your sets to build a better
world
to build something extraordinary
to be what you are always waiting to
become
the stakes in this game are insanely
high
for the first time in my life I am on
the right side of something
they not tell the whole truth
I want to be as great as I possibly can
be
that's what makes me a chain food
new fresh excited that's what I want
we're making history here
we can do this
I'm with you every step of the way
is my house
amazing it's incredible
so in case you missed it there's an
image of Queen Cersei hugging Tommen she
has short hair she could be wearing a
wig but I think the idea is that her
hair is partially grown back Lena Headey
freaking beautiful no matter what length
her hair is it's almost impossible to
make her look ugly inside is a different
matter Queen Cersei very ugly inside but
then we get a picture of Daenerys
looking all de Chelly like messed up
hair also freaking beautiful despite the
fact that she got drugged through flame
almost stabbed to death and flew halfway
across the country this looks like it's
happening sometime recently after kal
Jacko's khalasar picked her up at the
end of season 5 and of course we have
the man of the hour Ramsay Bolton
leading his army you can see the big
flayed man banners lowing in the
background that's the real purpose of
this video to talk about Ramsay Bolton
because right now he's sitting on top of
the world sure he lost Sansa so is super
pissed about that but he has this giant
army at his back so he probably feels
invincible isn't that just when the rug
gets pulled out from under you any time
it feels like things have gotten way too
comfortable for a character that's
that's when [ __ ] goes down there's been
a bunch of reports from the set about
scenes from like the finale from the
last couple of episodes so we actually
have a pretty good idea for the end game
for season 6 but just because that's
super spoilery please use spoiler tags
if you're going to talk about it in the
comments the question is is what is
Ramsey going to be doing before that
that's like ten weeks away from the
premiere and because they're circling
around to do some book stuff that they
skipped over like they're doing some
Jamie stuff from book for the day
skipped they're doing some Ironborn
stuff that they skip from book 4 and 5
and it even looks like they're giving
some Stannis stuff from winds of winter
to another big character but because
they changed a bunch of things I'm kind
of wondering if Ramsay Bolton is going
to have a version of the brave
companions storyline just reaving and
raping his way across the North just
exerting the dominance of the Bolton's
the problem is is that they needed Sansa
Stark to legitimize their claim Roose
Bolton was worried that the other lords
of the north wouldn't support their
claim even though the crown appointed
them wardens of the north without a
stark being in Winterfell just because
the North remembers the north is a very
insular community despite being a very
big land mass so what are they going to
do now that stance is gone maybe they'll
circle back around and do some Jane pool
fake Arya stuff from the books now they
changed a bunch of stuff for season 5
and everybody complained about it one of
the biggest changes was that Sansa Stark
ended up marrying Ramsay Bolton in the
books Sansa stays in the veil in the
crown wanting to maintain appearances
and keep the peace Mary's a fake Arya
Stark to Ramsay Bolton the fake Arya
Stark was Jane pool one of Santa's
friends from King's Landing now she was
on the show for a little while but
they've kind of done away with that
character she almost doesn't exist
anymore so Roose Bolton might try to
trot out a fake Sansa Stark while they
look for the real one just just to
maintain the peace now i know i said
ramsey brave companions but if you've
read the books then you know the brave
companions was actually locks group on
the show that was another minor change
from the boats the brave companions were
that group that cut Jamie's hand off
Vargo hOAT became the lock character of
the show and then they changed him even
more in the books the brave companions
are mostly reaving and raping in and
around Harrenhal so they've already kind
of done that in the show they might
bring that group back briefly for
Brienne storyline it seems like they've
kind of passed it by though but they
might have ransley doing similar types
of things in the north just right around
terrorizing the countryside the
interesting thing though is what is the
whole point what is Rameses goal in all
this it seems like they kind of dropped
that in season 5 like he found out that
he might be having a little brother they
would have a stronger claim to Roose
Bolton's title when he died now Ramsey
was legitimized so he's a legitimate
heir but a true born son would have a
much more legitimate claim in the eyes
of the kingdom so they gotta deal with
that too so Ramsay's going to be a
really busy guy like he has to deal with
the wildlings that are going to be in
the gift that's basically where all the
Wildings went when they came through the
wall it was this area south of here that
was given to them by Stannis so
eventually they're going to land on the
Bolton's radar then you have Rican Sansa
who are on the run then you have spoiler
character that might be coming back to
take some revenge I just say spoiler
term I think we all know who we're
talking about but just in case you don't
want to know about that i'll say it's
spoiler warning and you could talk about
in the comments if you want so if
anything I'd be really excited to see
some rugs get pulled out from ramsey but
let me know in the comments what do you
want to see Ramsay's character do in
season six he's one of the best villains
that the show has had I think he's a
much better villain than Joffrey was
even though Joffrey was a much more
spectacular villain I think at a certain
point though Joffrey became this
petulant child he became really annoying
as a villain so you're like yeah please
die and go away do not come back Ramses
everybody's terrible but i think the
actor is just a lot better so i think
they tried to extend his stay in the
narrative
you know make it much bigger than it was
in the books for all the things that Dan
and Dave change usually when they find a
really amazing actor they will try to
give them more scenes even if they
didn't exist in the books so that's
actually another good question if they
change Ramsey's story even more from the
books what would you want them to change
about Ramsey or the battle for
Winterfell also i should say they just
cast small John number for the TV show
so just confirms that some umber related
things are going to be happening in the
north I think what the show is going to
do is it's going to change the books in
the umbers will be the ones that have
Rickon instead of another house so
Rickon might show up at the last hearth
congratulations though to the last
week's giveaway winner Sarah Ashley you
win a twenty-dollar amazon gift card be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so i can get your
contact info because this trailer this
footage was kind of a surprise i'm just
going to push my Q&A video to a couple
more days later but i'm still starting a
new round of the giveaway so all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video real
simple and working on a new star wars
video so why does wait for that if you
haven't seen it you can click here for
the official season 60s or the Game of
Thrones season 6 teaser and you can
click here for all my Star Wars Episode
7 videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you